[Music]
hey are you my doctor not anymore
I'm off to become a world-famous knife
juggler but don't worry I called you an
uber
I don't need an uber man I need a doctor
by forever Nick blue lab coat how you
doing today
okay get you some lime in maybe a bottle
water as a temperature okay no it's
burning stop well let's see the app says
you just came out of a coma I'm a Google
that see what that is
you don't even know what a coma is
aren't you a doctor
nah man it's just my side hustle my
thrills passion is making house music
mixed up mashed up with 9-1-1 phone
calls I need real professional care how
is this legal you want a lawyer dude you
got caught with what yeah yeah so
there's this big-time video producer
right and he's got this mansion he's got
these like champagne ladies he's got
like these tigers and stuff it's gonna
be like I can't breathe I know oh hell
yeah I got an uber pull sorry man
what are you like a knife juggler sorry
dude I gotta take care of Lucas he's got
like knives mm so
[Music]
but ah
you